hundreds and thousands of people are
going to lose their homes
they will die let's be honest for a
cruel and desperate hope
of maximizing profit stop evictions
at all costs they brought living room
furniture into the streets
saying this is what the city would look
like as thousands face
eviction their demand canceled the rent
a lot of folks have had to choose
whether to eat or to pay rent
the federal government and many cities
and states have enacted a series of
temporary measures
halting residential evictions in the
united states
evictions were leading to unnecessary
cases of covid
and unnecessary deaths from koved dubbed
the tenant movement's giant killer by
one industry trade magazine
sia weaver is a rising star in new york
politics
so this is life-saving and that's the
most important thing
the cancel rent movement weaver told the
new york times is also about literally
rising up for real transformation in the
housing market
in new york that transformation is
underway and it's having a devastating
impact on landlords
the eviction moratorium isn't just
benefiting the poor it's allowing bad
actors to stop paying their rent without
consequence
meanwhile many small landlords are
seeing their life savings disappear
because they have no choice but to
maintain their buildings at a loss
position
one landlord who's been hurt by the
eviction moratorium is
ciao wai gao who works at a nail salon
and saved for 20 years to buy a house in
queens
in march of last year a squatter moved
in this person who didn't respond to our
interview request
is a drop out from an elite private
university and he has never paid rent
because of the eviction moratorium
there's no legal mechanism through which
gao can retake possession of his
property
meanwhile his bills are mounting
no payroll i'm so angry it's a robbery
i maybe i i
so in my story one landlord says this is
really a straightforward issue
it's robbery he's paying heat taxes and
a mortgage
so someone else and someone else is
living rent free and he has absolutely
no recourse
do you agree with that characterization
is this robbery no
i don't think it's robbery and we're
also not saying that the landlord can
never collect the rent that's not what
an eviction moratorium does it's
simply a pause so
no i don't agree with that i think it's
it's deeply
um misleading but practically speaking
this landlord will be very lucky i mean
just the way housing court runs
if he is able to collect back rent in
terms of the cost of hiring lawyers
the delays that come in in housing court
you don't have to be in the business of
being a landlord those are part of the
costs of being a landlord
that should be understood as part of the
deal and it is
[Music]
[Applause]
but owners say having almost no legal
recourse when their tenants
don't pay their rent is not something
they consider to be part of the deal
when investing in real estate
landlord groups around the country have
sued on the grounds that halting the
judicial process that allows them to
retake their property violates their due
process rights
and that the national moratorium is an
unconstitutional expansion of federal
power
gao is part of an association of about
two hundred chinese immigrant landlords
with tenants who have stopped paying
rent
what's
[Laughter]
here this landlord worked as a
housekeeper at a hotel that recently
closed down
she says her tenants stopped paying rent
over the summer and is demanding a
twelve thousand dollar cash payment to
move out
you know what they said how are you
making sure
i think it's really critical that mom
and pop landlords are prioritized for
aid right now
at the same time everyone has taken a
haircut they don't have a god-given
right to collect rent just like
hotels don't have a god-given right to
profit off of the tourism industry and
bars and restaurants don't have a
god-given night to like
serve people dinner and wine you know
[Applause]
[Music]
weaver says she feels for these
landlords but tenants are worse off
and we know as a matter of statistical
fact that renters are far less likely to
have wealth
and renters are far less likely to have
anything in savings i know that there's
some examples like the ones that you're
raising and
you know for and i feel for that person
and want them to get the resources that
they need from the state
the media has predicted a huge wave of
evictions in the united states
if the moratoriums are lifted and a new
york tenant activist dragged furniture
out into the streets to dramatize the
potential impact
but in new york before covid only about
one out of ten eviction filings ended in
a city marshal or sheriff
physically removing a tenant from a
dwelling however because there existed a
process through which landlords could
enforce their contracts and get tenants
who weren't paying their rent to come to
the negotiating table or move out they
had legal recourse
one problem with the eviction moratorium
is that in practice it's not only
impacting those in need it's also
allowing tenants who can't afford their
rent
to take advantage of their landlords you
can pay
you can live here you can pay money
and then you find department move out
juan who asked that we only use her last
name owns a house in queens and works as
a home health aide caring for an elderly
couple
her husband is a waiter at this
restaurant in chinatown
though he's barely been able to work
since the pandemic she says that her
tenant owes her more than 80 thousand
dollars in back rent
every month i need to pay the money
where has the money can pay
i only the way i keep walking walking
walking
but i just want the government open the
court juan says that if her tenants were
unemployed or financially distressed
she'd be willing to work with them
these people no money i can help for all
okay pay later or something but these
people know the people have money
reason wasn't able to reach her tenants
for comment so we're not using their
names in this story
but we did find that the father who has
a criminal record is currently employed
in the construction industry
and while his girlfriend's mother and
children live in juan's apartment
he and his girlfriend are renting a
second apartment in this house in queens
village where they've also stopped
paying rent and owe twelve thousand
dollars to the couple that owns the
house who are also chinese immigrants
but it's not only immigrant landlords
who are being taken advantage of
sharon redhead who's the owner of a
building in brooklyn told the new york
daily news that some of her tenants were
out of work have kept up with their rent
while others with jobs aren't paying any
rent at all
clarence hammer is the owner of a
two-family home with a tenant who isn't
paying rent but is subletting rooms at a
profit
the new york post told the story of 88
year old harlem landlord david hausen
suffering from alzheimer's with a tenant
who hasn't paid a dime since 2016
were completely destitute his daughter
told the post
the idea that there's a handful of
renters who
are maybe working and saying like oh i
have the money and i'm just not going to
pay right now
all of the data is showing that that's
an operation the data that shows people
who are borrowing to pay rent the data
that shows that people that renters
48 of renters are behind on their
housing costs compared to six percent of
property owners who are behind on their
housing costs like
the data is just with us weaver is
referring to census data that doesn't
single out landlords but that does show
that renters are more financially
distressed than people who own their own
homes
and newspapers have recounted the
stories of many tenants in crisis
such as diba gay whose wife recently
died of heart disease and who lost his
job stocking groceries
i don't want to lose my house too he
told the times and halima abdul wahab
who says she and her two children are at
risk of homelessness i'm at a job where
i don't make that much but i just try to
maintain as much as i can she said
rent is not the only thing that has to
be paid every month but these
individuals can be helped with the type
of direct aid that the government has
been providing since the early days of
the pandemic
through interest-free loan stimulus
checks and a substantial increase in
unemployment benefits
cities and states have also spent
billions in federal money on rent relief
programs
these programs bring their own set of
problems and trade-offs and those funded
by philanthropy have proven more
effective than government financed ones
but if tenants are receiving the aid
they need owners should still be able to
turn to the courts
if they don't pay their rent weaver says
this approach fails to help populations
that are hard to reach with direct
aid like undocumented immigrants her
organization helped to draft a proposed
state law
under which the government would cover
missing rent no matter the recent
tenants hadn't paid
and with strings attached for landlords
to accept the money because we think
it'll get the money out the fastest
right the
landlords have rent ledgers they have
operating statements they have rent
rolls
but there's another reason weaver and
her political allies want to make
landlords dependent on federal subsidies
emergency policies enacted in times of
crisis are prone to becoming permanent
which some members of the council rent
movement say is the goal
we need to think about the role that
exclusion
and profit which are the sort of
characteristics of the private property
market
have played and think about different
systems and structures that we could put
into place
that would help more people be housed
weaver would like to see the entire real
estate industry
restructured in a model akin to public
housing but for rich people too
in public housing people are paying 30
of their income what i am envisioning is
a world
in which the housing is owned by a
collective and people are paying 30
of their income in order to live in
their housing if your income is zero you
pay zero if your income is five hundred
thousand dollars a year you're paying 30
of that and the government is providing
the sort of
the government is the sort of owner
or not even the owner the government
doesn't have to be the owner but the
government is what's
making sure all of that sort of works in
cash flows
the debt to gdp ratio right now is the
highest since
world war ii trump left us with an
additional
7.8 trillion dollars in debt and biden's
agenda would add 11 trillion on top of
what we're already spending over the
next 10 years so
how can the federal government also
afford to
start subsidizing rental housing costs
the federal government
makes money the federal government can
provide money for those
so it's by printing money sure
america is beautiful nobody parents
it's not beautiful okay this is ugly
dao his wife and two daughters are
living in a one-room studio
unable to move into the building they
own and they're afraid to contact the
person squatting there
out of fear that they'll be sued for
[Music]
harassment
when gao and other immigrant landlords
decided to come to the united states to
create a better life
this is not the american dream they
thought they were buying into
[Music]
you